photo louisa richard brûlé reçoit
quotidiennement la visite de 20 à 25 ans
dont sauvage dans sa cour
les oiseaux sont attiré chez lui par la
nourriture qu'ils laissent pour les
chevreuils et par là mangeoires
d'oiseaux
cette année ces animaux sont de plus en
plus visible à la recherche de
nourriture en raison de la rigueur de
l'hiver en augmentation du nombre de
signalements dindon you une très bonne
saison de reproduction l'année passée
puis cette année diva est difficile pour
les dindons la présence remarquée des
dindons sauvages préoccupe aussi les
agriculteurs puisque ces oiseaux sont
friands de céréales bain et en plus les
producteurs en plus de problèmes mais on
ne vous dira des récoltes ça occasionne
des coûts et coproducteur de pertes sont
plus des pertes au niveau des rendements
surtout d'un serial les tigres et
revoilà le blé la fédération des
producteurs de grains outaouais
laurentides réclame d'ailleurs un
meilleur contrôle de la population de
dindons sauvages pourraient trouver une
solution j'ai encore niang orientaux de
monter on n'est pas là pour les
exterminer je pense que l'idée est
peut-être que la solution passe par la
chasse chasse qui est en expansion c'est
à dire qu'ils deviennent plus simples au
québec
en dix ans entre 2008 et 2018
le nombre de permis émis pour la chasse
au dindon est passé de plus de 2000 à
près de 20000 ça marche une moule pour
les agriculteurs la chasse au dindon
pourrait encore être intensifiées ce qui
ne déplairait pas aux chasseurs où on
trouve que les dindons y en a jamais
assez
la chasse au dindon sauvage s'ouvre
d'ailleurs le 26 avril
ici florence guaino radio-canada
gatineau